welcome back to new rock stars thor love
and thunder is just around the corner
and hiding behind the next corner gore
the god butcher with a knife you better
check ancestry.com to make sure that the
sky daddy ho zeus ain't your grandpappy
because that pale ass for the god
butcher is going to get you if you go
demigod you better not be a demigod and
because zeus he was sleeping around he's
like i don't know if he read any
mythology but that man he just couldn't
keep it in his pants but who needs
vitamin d when you've got vitamin
darkness in your heart because gordon
the god butcher is a pale pale ass boy
this is rogue theory the show where we
pitch the wildest theories for the nerdy
titles that we love my name is mt and
going wrong with me today is the queen
goddess of chaos and wife of the mad
titan herself it's jessica clements
what's going on jess uh not much i'm
having a good time thanks for inviting
me
[Laughter]
no problem oh wow that was sweet this
morning a little sweet jessica this
morning i like it uh it's glad to have
you jess because they under eye things
are on once they're off i'll start being
mean again
they contain jess it's like yeah wow
this is called just
um and wouldn't you know it it's the
scarlet goddess of pugs and love it's
whitney van laningham what's going on
with me ah that is who i am i do love
pugs yay
yeah hi it's me my pug is actually right
here he he just he just looked at me
when i said pag and now he's looking at
me like why didn't you bring me on the
podcast mom you're the worst mom hello
pugsley we love you everybody loves you
they say hi
sorry
sorry i'm just telling you and of course
we cannot forget to mention the all
father of fun himself it's off-screen
producer brandon what's going on brandon
oh yeah baby i love to have a good fun
time and then take a nap get into that
odin's sleep
as soon as it's time to clean up it's
like oh my god i got a nap sorry i can't
clean up yep pretty much uh that's how
it is once you uh reach a certain age
i'm feeling it myself i'm just like oh i
can't have fun because yeah i just run
out of energy
i love getting old
like parties over at 9 30. time to go to
bed good night everybody pretty much
that's the dilemma of your 30s ladies
and gentlemen this is what you have to
look forward to kids it's a bad idea
yeah don't get old just don't
there's a reason kurt cobain
you know and the 27 club they had
something going they just didn't want to
get tired at 30. it's true that's why
peter pan would kill all those lost boys
when they got too old because they were
boring yeah he was like you guys can't
run around as much yeah you're dead now
two doors oh yeah the post credits see
the peter pan's wild guys
but like yeah he just goes into it
it's like it's like the youngling scene
from uh for revenge of the world but
with peter pan and the lost boys
no that's too dark i hate it
i said it and now i hate it i hate that
i said it i brought this into the world
we could cut it out if we if you don't
want it we can cut it out no keep it in
live with my shame didn't say it again
play it twice just kidding but now heads
up gang we're changing things up a
little bit here on rogue theory because
instead of the you know panelists
pitching their rogues theories like
we've done in the past here's what we're
gonna do i'm gonna tell you my own super
rogue and out there theory to you guys
my beautiful panel of intelligent nerds
and we're gonna chat about them and then
at the end i would like you three to
decide whether it's too rogue or just
rogue enough is it rogus or bogus
i love that
rogueis or bogus i don't know i just
literally put that out of my ass right
now i like it i really like it i think
it's good i think it's real good keep it
uh which leads us to our first topic of
today could zeus have been gore the god
butcher's god because check this out
rogue squadron because we know from the
trailers from 411 thunder that zeus and
the golden gods of olympus have been
living their lives of luxury eating
grapes and flicking strangers too hard
up in mountain olympus instead of you
know being the loving gods who protect
their loving worshipers from harm and
those who are familiar with the
character of gore the god butcher from
the comics know that the main reason
gore started butchering gods in the
first place was because he was just
pretty pissed off about the gods
ignoring his phone calls while his wife
and children casually just passed the
[ __ ] away from disaster and famine this
is not very nice that god's not to
listen to your prayers so now gay now
what if what if the all father of the
terran greek gods zeus was also the all
father assigned to gore the god
butcher's sector of the universe like
what if zeus the lightning [ __ ] himself
was too busy getting that good good from
the goddesses to go give gore's
god-loving family the gift of life huh
what what if what if that's the case
what do you guys think that's like an
interesting theory like who who assigns
gods to planets
is that like the celestial's jobs yeah
how do you know which planet gets which
god because we know that like the
celestials do that too like the
celestials assign like eternals to
planets and they assign a celestial to
be born from the planet but like yeah
how do how does a god get chosen for a
planet
you think it could be heirshim that's
just like all right odin you get this
section with earth and then zeus you get
this section of the universe with a
horse planet yeah you get this part you
get this part i mean the universe is
huge it's like a delivery zone you know
like how sometimes uh you know like a
pizza can't be delivered to your house
because you're outside delivery range
that's what it was with gore he was just
outside of delivery range from the gods
and he and nobody listened to him nobody
came together sorry you're just too far
away too much
it's a lot it's a lot to handle
i really like that theory though mt it
could it could be one of those gods who
were just like laying around all day
eating grapes getting their dicks sucked
like it could be one of them they
weren't helping gore cause they were too
busy it's true it's true
it could happen what do you think jess
what do you think of this rogue theory
of mine um i think it's okay um
um the eye patches are off the eye
patches are off the eye patches are off
badges
the truth has come out the eye patches
are off
i like the idea of arishim
dividing like the divide and conquering
galaxies i guess for gods because then
that would make sense to like why
different cultures have different gods
um and why they represent different gods
yeah because he's got he's got hoes in
different area codes you know
yes just like ludicrous
yes buddha is in fact a hoe in a
different area but it's
true but
i like that idea the second part i
didn't like but i can't remember what
the second part was now so i i
truthfully doesn't matter
i can't remember what it was yeah but i
i like the irishman stuck with me more
so because i was like that would make
sense so wait so is your theory overall
that you think
zeus was assigned to gore to gore the
god butcher's planet
in what world do the gods actually help
the people uh i guess is my question
that would be for that theory um well in
our world we see odin i mean thor helps
us right it seems like we're the ancient
people right odin and thor like oh did
help the people of norway way back in
the day that's the only i i guess it's
it's like yeah that's but that's also
why people didn't like thor in the
comics he wasn't actually growing their
crops and wasn't actually coming to help
their families he just kind of comes to
earth and saves earth sometimes he
doesn't go to like anyone else and also
a lot of his savings that we've seen in
mcu really stays in new york so it's
like what about the other people that
are in different continents on or like
earth he can only serve people in the
774 or the 212 area codes because that's
how this works he's the hoe for those
that make sense so you can't hog all the
area codes the day-to-day work that the
gods are doing you don't notice right
it's like if the gods are protecting
your planet from the frost giants by
going to
judenheim and fighting them there you
don't really know but you're like why
aren't you making my crops grow and
odin's like i got bigger things to worry
about and a lot of that is maybe placed
on the people right you're like oh we
have these gods and they're supposed to
control all this stuff and the gods are
like whoa we didn't say we would control
like where the river flows or uh how
much sun you get uh during the growing
season or whether or not your wheat
harvested or not like you you put that
on us you kept coming up with all this
stuff that we're in charge of we're just
here to keep the aliens out like that's
our main job so
that's on gore and gore's people for
valuing the gods too maybe maybe they
valued them too much
so it sounds like you're a piece of [ __ ]
brandon it sounds like just you're in
the ass listen but god's got a lot to do
all right the gods have a lot i can talk
to brandon like this we spend every day
together we spend every day together for
at least one hour i can treat him like
i mean that's uh
treat him whatever i want
you guys
if you spend every day with one person
you can treat them however you want them
joking
whatever you want uh okay yeah then i i
think that's plausible that would also
be really funny to see in thor love and
thunder uh
gore be like you were my god and here
you are
ripping the clothes off of this other
god that sucks ripping the clothes off
of this poor man
yeah yeah yeah that's he's like this is
another poor man and now i'm gonna
attack you guys for attacking them i
actually think though i'm gonna present
a different rogue theory for this
because i okay go for it i think that
the god of gore's planet was possibly
the the nowhere skull
because you know how it's like the
celestial i've always thought that gore
the god butcher was probably the one who
decapitated that bad boy with his necro
sword and that it's because nowhere was
like the celestial or god that was
supposed to be in charge of his planet
and that he was the first one he killed
on the spree because he was like hey
[ __ ] you man my [ __ ] wife and kids
[ __ ] died because of you
and like yes that's that's my personal
rogue theory on on who i really like
that the god butchers oh gee god was and
then like gore like got a taste for
killing gods and he's like well i'd like
to do this again
uh and he's just killing gods yeah well
let me just do this to all of them
because that was super easy and fun
i would like to do this one more time at
least
and like maybe killing guys who don't
deserve it who are doing their job who
we should respect and give thanks to
thanks for keeping our planet safe and
then gore's just like i'm sorry i got a
thing against all gods
sorry all of them
but i love this because like you know we
know in the comics in in in marvel in
general that each celestial has their
own job and their own role and i believe
in the comics there is a celestial
called the celestial gardener um who
goes around and i think he goes around
maintaining worlds so like what if
nowhere was like had like a job of like
being a celestial gardener i don't know
if this is correct i'm just pulling this
out of my weird knowledge
well wasn't the celestial gardener also
supposed to be kind of ajax uh ajax's
character in eternals uh yeah
in the chat like you guys normally do i
like the idea that nowhere wasn't the
god of gore and he's just like he's
showing up in space one day and he's
giant and he's in the sky like we saw
how like arizona showed up on earth and
gore's like that's my god and nowhere's
like i'm just the gardener buddy
i'm just here
[Applause]
and he's like i killed my god and
nowhere's like i wasn't the god i'm just
i'm just gardening i mean it wasn't even
me wrong place wrong time yeah yeah yeah
don't show up in the sky what's it
called well like there is a gore does
have a special relationship with uh
nowhere in the comics because the actual
necrosword is linked to
the the body or the essence of nowhere
so like it would make sense for gore to
have been the one to kill nowhere in the
mcu as well because like there is that
special connection between the sword and
nowhere so i i really love that idea
that god being
gore is god that didn't listen what a
jerk of a celestia but yeah celestials
are jerks all the time so i guess it's
not really they really are they're like
the ultimate
planetary jerks they got a lot going on
we got to respect the celestials respect
them they gave us life they're making
stars did you ever go stargazing that's
the celestials baby you better thank
them
there's just a little bit of a price to
pay at the end but this is okay it's a
real problem it's just dying in an
apocalypse
in an explosion apocalypse where
everything you know is simultaneously
hey you could die any day you could die
any day seriously earth is just in the
middle of a vacuum of space we could
just blow up any minute think about that
because what if we blow it up destroy us
at all but if we blow up
while we're recording this podcast oh i
hope so i got so many bills to pay this
money man my only regret is that we
weren't live streaming
we were talking about it that would be
great
like what a coincidence i also like what
do you guys think of the idea of like
what if all these gods like zeus and
odin they were supposed to be paying
attention to other planets but they
favored our planet and earth and so gore
is like yo what's so special about earth
[ __ ] all these guys zeus we're sexy baby
we're sexy that's why exactly come on
we're sexy we've got the internet to
share the sexiness you've got it all
baby you got people
you don't have anything
you don't even have a family
[Laughter]
sorry i'm like
i think it might be right empty and that
like they're they're kind of setting up
it looks like in the trailer this
pantheon of gods right with zeus in
charge of everything right it would be
interesting if like
it all the like zeus was supposed to be
in charge of like all of the gods and
it's really just let it go like he's
palpatine and this is the senate right
and he's supposed to be in charge of
everyone right he's not watching what's
going on on the little things and
whoever you know whatever god he
assigned to gore's planet like messed up
and like maybe he doesn't even know he's
dead yet he hasn't been checking his
emails because he's zeus he's got a lot
to do
and yeah to whitney's point like earth
is full of sexy sexy people and they're
like yeah we like hanging out on earth
we don't like hanging out on gore's
planet it's boring
boo
you want to go to earth
snore am i all right oh
god i'm roasted again
more like snore the god butcher
just kidding he's very exciting he seems
very exciting he's looks very like
people are saying that gore the god
butcher was like one of the best marvel
villains ever yeah i heard that from
like the test screenings i'm excited if
that's true cool this is also my beef
with dc putting harlequin and everything
cause you can't you can't kill harley
quinn [ __ ] idiot stop putting her and
[ __ ] um love her to death but stop
putting her [ __ ] [ __ ] when she showed
off her holster and i had the marks of
how many people she killed i was like
that's not that many
i said why are you so sad
honestly dude that's that you don't have
a very high calculator was it people she
saved it was people she killed i'll add
to your theory mt uh and you and i were
kind of talking about this yesterday a
little bit
you know we know we know zeus likes
mortal women right he loves to mess
around a little bit true
and i think maybe zeus if zeus was
gore's god
maybe zeus messed around with gore's
wife
uh and has really pissed off gore a lot
and maybe he found out his own son
was a demigod what if what if gore
in a fit of anger and passion killed his
own family and killed everyone on his
planet and it was like i'm gonna come
kill all these gods who've been sneaking
around with our immortal women uh
i don't know if that makes him likeable
though i don't know if that makes him
likeable
it makes him slut-shaming as hell and we
don't [ __ ] shame on gore's planet and we
don't do that there
but i do like the idea that that that
zeus messed around with gore's wife
hello i'm zeus i'm a lot hotter than
your dumb starving husband like what
like oh my god that would blow my mind
that would be like the space soap opera
to end all space soap operas
your man can't bring home any bacon but
i got an eggplant for you right it's
like my bones got protein surrounded
it's also like everyone on that planet
looks like that also i'd be so mad i'd
be like you're you could feed us you're
a god
you don't need to [ __ ] me i i need food
i need nourishment [ __ ] sex
yeah take me out to dinner first am i
right ladies this is not the kind of
meat i wanted why not both why not both
why not both the teeth was he only gonna
do it to me i have a i have a child
brandon that needs to eat as well are
you trying to fight me
i'll make you some more grapes what do
you want
what do you want you want more grapes
here have some grapes i'm gonna get tons
of grapes boom grapes grapes grapes
there's a guy that can turn water to
wine i hate this god
that's what you would suggest
give me the give me the one that's the
alcohol fun party one give me that one
the greek's got dionysius he's alcohol
fun party time they're great
but also dionysus is a problem and i
feel like he would ruin everything
not hermes hermes did nothing but
deliver messages for you
all right continue
i'll fight for hermes another day
hermes is just save the ups
this is a pro hermes podcast everyone
this absolutely better be
don't shoot the messenger don't shoot
the messenger baby keep going literally
that's the one thing people tell you do
not shoot the messenger and you're doing
it don't do it uh but now it is time for
judgment my beautiful people because i
presented a theory i would like my
beautiful nerd friends to tell me
whether it's rogus or bogus
let's start with whitney is this idea of
gore the god butcher having beef with
zeus because zeus was his god two robe i
don't think it's too rogue i don't think
it's bogus i think it's rogus as hell i
think that that's totally an option
because zeus is like the epitome like
when you picture like just a luxurious
[ __ ] just
bathing in opulence while the rest of us
die and starve it's like a you picture
elon musk be you picture zeus that's how
it is so
that's why no it's 100 plausible to me
i'm in baby i'm in for the rogues all
right i got a rogus
but what do you think jess two rogues or
two bogus i don't think the i will say
the
rogueis theory is assuming anyone's
gonna straight to your face tell you
your thing is bogus
then to show up on youtube why would i
ever come at you like that
i don't mean i'm a mean person but i
would never say that your theory is
stupid
okay okay is it too long i should say i
don't want to say
i feel like bogus in this situation
doesn't mean stupid it just you know
like like bill and ted's bogus adventure
like it means that in that way where
it's like it's it's silly
it's silly i've never seen it i've never
seen people but um well oh god go go
watch it a little bit at least a little
jess yeah no i think your theories are
fun yeah yeah okay what what else do you
want from me what else do you want from
me you want me to dance for you like we
have to
the new format is like we vote at the
end where it's like yes or no yeah yeah
it's good it's good to me yeah yes okay
hooray
oh i don't know sorry let's figure it
out from me and brandon what do you
think i'll show you how it's done
jessica this theory is too rogue wow
i don't like it it's too wrong
i think zeus is stuck with earthlings uh
there's too many gods on earth and
that's gonna be gore's problem because
there's too many gods on earth we got
too many yeah we do i think
that actually makes a lot of sense when
you say two rogue i think of like
whitney's theories which are like i
think he's gonna go around a corner and
suck a dick in an alley
all right all right well that's the
things that she says i don't say these
things anything
that's race yeah that's where i'm like
yeah that's really rogue that's rogue
this was not this was compared to what
this is
or whatever
none of my serious dick today you guys i
don't think that nowhere as the god of
gorge planet sucked anyone's dick i
don't think so at all not even a little
bit never not once i like
more than mts no offense empty
i was like i liked your theory a lot i i
think i don't think either of them were
too rogue but brandon does
but brandon's the king of us okay two
two thumbs up and one thumbs down that's
not bad i'll take it i'll take any like
because you guys are the smartest people
that i know so like
your opinion matters a lot to me so i'll
take anything so thank you guys for for
sharing that with me and uh who knows
maybe i don't i personally don't think
that zeus is gore's god i just i just
wanted to present a super rogue
one about it today i think it's cool man
i think it's a very fun theory i like i
actually really liked all of our
theories
today like all of them i think are super
plausible and fun so i'm into every
answer every one game today i think the
point of rogue theory is just to serve
as an extra option as like what if to
marvel as just like oh i think it would
have looked honestly i use rook theory
as a way to be like oh i think i would
have preferred your movie more than the
movie that i got
so
that's always how i think of rogue
theories which i think your theory was
great yeah that's the nicest i'll ever
be now continue
well up next the lovely and talented
jessica clemons will be pitching a very
interesting miss marvel theory for us to
discuss but first let us discuss your
wardrobe people and how broke you look
without our new rockstars.com merch god
damn
just kidding but i mean you're beautiful
and handsome yeah always and you don't
really need our merch to look beautiful
handsome but it'll help because i i've
heard so many people that wear our merch
say that they they get laid a lot more
now i'm just kidding that's not true but
maybe it'll work for you it's true
everyone who wears new stars merch is
getting guts it's happening
they get laid if yeah it's it's
literally it's they're getting laid
they're getting paid that's what happens
when you wear our merch baby get in on
it and during a recession we need both
we need both but yes please pick up our
new latest obsession shirt inspired by
miss marvel and when you purchase this
limited edition shirt you unlock the
ability to get a custom shout out that
will appear on inside marvel our miss
marvel after show hosted by eric voss
and some weird person named mt so check
out all of our awesome merch options
over at
newrockstarsmerch.com now are people
trying to make plans with you this
summer as if you aren't already booked
and busy you're just gonna have to tell
them to try again in the fall you've got
pool days pride parades bachelor parties
and beach vacations waiting for you so
many plans but thankfully me undies
wants to help make this summer the most
comfortable one that you will never
forget because you're living your best
life the last thing you want to worry
about is butt sweat all right but sweat
is the worst
sitting down with butt sweat like you're
just sliding all over the chair you
might slip and fall very dangerous so we
here at new rock stars love me undies
for all their fun patterns and designs
on their super soft fabrics and we love
getting a fresh pair of underwear in the
mail every month it's what gives me my
serotonin and when i don't get it i'm
sad when you're comfy and feeling good
you're more present to enjoy all of your
summer plans it's like science or
something meundies has the lightest and
most breathable fabrics to keep you cool
and comfortable wherever you go from
undies bralettes and socks to loungewear
and swimwear you can find something for
all of your plans and meundies also
releases new prints all the time like
their limited edition pride collection
you can match with your partner friends
or even your dog so find your ultimate
summer comfort in sizes extra small to
4xl and me unnies has a great offer for
rogue theory fans for any first-time
purchasers you get 15 off and for a
limited time if you sign up for their
free to join me undies membership you
get 25 off your first membership item so
to get 15 off your first order 25 off
your first membership item and 100
satisfaction guaranteed go to
meundies.com rockstars that's
meundies.com
rockstars and we also want to thank
ferrari for sponsoring today's rogue
theory it can be difficult to find the
right outfit in the summer when every
day is different and weather can change
at the drop of a hat luckily parody
makes it way easier they make the
perfect clothes for all seasons verity
is a family run brand making high
quality timeless clothing with modern
design and functionality it's the kind
of effortless style you want every time
you go digging into your closet of that
set that shirt that dress that feels
like you've had them for years maybe
it's a gorgeous print and it looks like
it might be vintage but it fits so well
that it feels like it was made just
yesterday just for you well that's
parody off-screen producer and break
room bad boys zach and brandon love
their ferrity clothes it's what makes
them the most stylish guys in the office
at all times right brandon oh yeah
always so stylish in my parody exactly
and parody's so confident in the quality
of their stuff that they have a lifetime
guarantee of quality they replace or fix
your clothes forever no matter what even
if the earth explodes ferry will be
there on a comet just making sure that
your [ __ ] is looking correct so talk
about making it easier to get dressed
and right now ferrari is giving all
rogue theory listeners 20 off that is 20
off 2-0 so head to faritybrand.com rogue
and use the code rogue at checkout to
snag 20 off all of your new spring
staples that's code rogue at ferrity
h e r t y brand dot com slash rogue for
twenty percent off
veritybrand.com
rogue go there today now gang it is time
for our second rogue theory topic and
it's going to start off and be hosted by
our lovely clemens what's going on jess
yeah
i'm so
tired you guys um i almost fell asleep
you started reading it's okay i'm
my period's hitting hard this month like
a lot of people bro
did you say ew brandon no i said oh i
said sorry
i'm gonna be known right now and today
that brandon brandon is one of those
guys who protested turning red no he did
he was like no
i will not be ashamed of this
i grew up with two beautiful women in my
household and i supported them all the
way and even though i had
i had the main my bathroom was the guest
bathroom that everyone had to access and
i was i said please put all your
products in my bathroom so they oh
you're such a sweet a good brother
a king among kings respect women
so yes i am running in the second half
of rogue theory because i have broke
theories that are not good so my theory
today is that
i think in miss marvel miss marvel's
lineage goes so long and so deep that
it's attached to that of the watchers
and i have theories to back it up i'm
going to tell you what i know from miss
marvel i'm going to tell you what i know
about the watcher and i'm going to tell
you how they combine and why i'm correct
so
first off we know from the comics that
miss marvel was genetically her family's
lineage was genetically altered by cree
and they don't went down all these
generations to her being inhuman that's
how she got her superpowers right in the
comics then we go to the comics with the
watcher who the watchers uh the watchers
race is so technology technologically
advanced that they wanted to offer it up
to the world so they started with one
planet and the planet basically killed
themselves with the atomic energy and
they said you know what no more we're
not helping anybody else and basically
the king of the watchers was like we're
not going to interfere with anyone's
lives anymore and owatu is like what
happens when they need us and he's like
out of sight out of mind we're not
dealing with it anymore but the watcher
himself too was so every time there's
one issue of comic book lines where he's
been watching earth and he becomes so
attached to earth because he feels like
he's just been watching them so much not
like in like a love love love wave just
like i need to help them so that's why
he warned them about galactus coming to
in fantastic four he dies to nick fury
he intervenes eventually into and
honestly he gets in trouble for it so he
feels this closeness to earth so now
when i merge them together i think you
can combine the theory from the original
comics from ms marvel that she got it
from genetically altered by cree but
maybe she's genetically altered by the
super race that is uh the watchers so
these are my three theories of why it
hap it has to happen one we saw that uh
what we think is the ancestral plane
voss even said that the people on the
ancestral plane at avengers con when
marvel jumps into her little
her little power space we see people
that silhouette looks like the watcher
with the white eyes i do think those are
the feet the the race of the watchers
because in one comic the watchers are
all dead and watsu's just been watching
because he's looking for the other
watchers and seeing if they exist on any
other plane so that could still be a
theory that could be true number two the
watcher doesn't essentially have bengals
it kind of resembles like the what
wonder woman has but i think if he did
become close to the gram miss marvel's
grandma and then genetically altered her
he could have made the bengals for her
so she could help support her using the
powers which is in the original miss
marvel comics and is now canon in
episode 2 where he says the power you
already had deep down the bangles just
help you like organize it so i'm like
could still hold up and then my third
reason for why the watcher is related to
ms marvel is the crystals from the
watcher and what if resemble the
crystals that miss marvel uses too well
it can not be that family that and i
re-watched go re-watch what if when uh
ultravision realizes that like i can
hear you and the watchers crystals are
the exact same look consistency of the
crystal she uses her powers and if you
are making the like bands to help
control their powers why wouldn't you
just give them a sliver of your powers
which are the crystals and he can do yes
he's been taking the bands to make her
dance why wouldn't you not do this why
don't you do this
why don't you make her dance
because i think vos mentioned it
slightly with just saying that in ms
marvel's avengers con right that those
were the watchers i think he's on to
something i think it's true and i think
it would bring reason to bring the
watcher out of what if and also because
the watchers don't they don't do
anything they just watch so give them a
bigger platform and that platform be
that their race is attached to miss mark
boom boom
i think it was some watcher because watu
and what if mentions being so lonely all
the time and no mention of like i was
once in love with someone else and also
there was a girl
with a grandma without grandma she
wasn't a grandma yet wasn't my grandma
yeah not yet
free grandmas if we think about it not
me basically i mean i'm not gonna have
kids but i like to think that i will
still be a grandmother oh when you're oh
yeah just your grandma
yeah you don't need to have kids to be a
grandmother
you just have to reach grandma age and
start acting like that's true i get i
have i had auntie behavior before i was
an auntie yeah so i think that's true
that's true i already have grandma
behavior dude i keep minnie snickers in
my freezer i carry around some werther's
original in my pockets
i have uh grandma bones um i have
grandma you do have geriatric bones yeah
i've seen it jessica jessica do you
think that kamala's great-grandma who
this watcher maybe fell in love with do
you think that's why she like
she wasn't uh involved in like the train
store or she was already gone at that
point when he tells the story of
targetion
when that when
[Music]
yeah cause that was the little girl on
the train platform was uh kamala's
grandma right her mom's mom and the
great grandma wasn't around and the dad
used to said like we didn't know no one
knows what happened to her she's just
disappeared or whatever do you think she
like dipped out on the family and was
like i'm going back with the watchers
like i'm gonna go he's gonna pull me
into like the weird watcher zone this is
what i'm obsessed with and this is what
i'm sticking with just and this is
coming from a writer background of like
dru drama a drama
if you will so i like the idea and what
i was holding on to was like everyone
being like yeah she was a snake she did
all these bad things like the auntie's
talking about the illuminati's at the um
which is so funny by the way that name
is just so good
when they were talking about her and
being so shady and i was like i think
she left i think just kind of like if
you guys watch bridgette in season two
she left out on the marriage she was
supposed to be in for a watcher
and so i do think she kind of left her
family but it's like leaving it for the
better maybe that wasn't someone she
wanted to be with and this is someone
that she didn't want to be with and also
maybe it doesn't have to be love it
could just be an interest in science and
just being interested in like how far
like you could go with knowledge because
you can't do it unless you actually do
it does that make sense she's trying to
moana the situation she wants yeah she's
trying to go yeah she wants to see how
far she can go now see i was about to
say that this to me sounds like an
encanto situation oh okay the grandma is
like a bruno and so i'm thinking like we
don't talk about grandma no you know
besides that making a wonderful song
with updated lyrics to be about the
geriatric community um
also i think what if like what if her
powers went wrong and the family cast
her out because her powers weren't
serving them in the way that they needed
it or like something like something went
wrong something you know she caused some
kind of catastrophe with her powers and
they banished her
being like no you are no longer a part
of this family you [ __ ] this up
i would like that because in the comics
i was sticking my guns to this from the
comics and miss marvel and i don't think
we're gonna see it because he's going to
a school in california instead of
wakanda she
got so far deep in being a hero that she
injured her friends like her friends she
realized she was locking up people she
was playing i'm so sorry
for truck
hold for normal la traffic
uh
it's probably just a normal mustang just
driving over a human mm-hmm so
hey
tight tight tight
um
but no i i stick to my guns for this in
the comics but i doubt it's gonna happen
because bruno is going to cal poly but
she injures bruno when a bomb goes off
in the door and she it was because she
was blinded by being a superhero versus
being a friend she was playing really
really bad cop instead of being like
genuinely these people aren't doing
anything wrong um she was doing like
there's so many superheroes that don't
know the lie batman she was playing
batman where it's like batman doesn't
see she's doing wrong but batman is a
menace to society
but batman is literally a bad person
yeah i'm sorry but when robert battenson
just like led that card chase through
the
city they took out like so many people
and then he didn't even catch him
didn't even get him that time and i was
just like batman you destroyed like nine
city blocks jesus christ that's what she
did
in the call she literally did that in
the comics with some great analogy jess
i fully understand yeah she did it in
the comics with a bomb and so the that
situation could i would love for that
situation to ripple but start with the
grandma i it was such a good part in the
comics for me because it was like she
lost she was losing everybody but like
her best friend was always there for her
until he got blown up by a door
and then he went to a contract
but yeah i would love for that to happen
um
that's my theory you know i
really like this idea in particular
because of like that um that story we
know about um muniba's mother as a small
child and like what if the watcher was
watching out for his daughter and he was
like oh let's look where's my little
girl oh yeah he made the stars like what
if i'm helping her
get to the yeah
that's as close as he could to intervene
that's as close as he could to interview
and he was like i can't intervene but i
need to help some way
um
that's really cute i hope it's that i
love that let's hope they do it
really cool to see the watcher just be
like i love my daughter but i can't be
with her so like here's the only thing i
can do to help her that'd be so nice
that would be so sweet i love that so
much
but no i i love the connection between
the crystals that um the watcher
abuse to watch everyone to kamala's
powers dude i don't even think of that
that's so smart that's so smart i
literally did not even think about that
you are a hundred percent right as soon
as i saw the crystals in episode two i
was like it's the crit it's the same
crystal
i was like how dare they use the exact
same makeup how dare they oh but no but
we also see in the thor love and thunder
trailer that um jane foster comes in
into this weird hallway of like uh the
watcher eon and like just basically
everyone that has something that marvel
calls cosmic awareness and i think that
it'd be really really dope if miss
marvel had a bit of that cosmic
awareness from her potential father the
watcher because um i feel like this is
where we're going for the mcu moving
forward i think that jane foster might
end up getting the cosmic awareness that
she has in the comics and uh and just
marv captain marvel in general um i
believe uh genus vel the genus vel
version of captain marvel actually went
crazy because he was endowed with all
this cosmic awareness i think it's like
a marvel thing like maybe each of them
will end up getting cosmic awareness i
don't know he's going wild with this but
yeah no i really know now that's what
now that's rogus
now that's right
rogue is bogey oh my god i did not even
expect a theory like this my god that
was real good i've been sitting on it i
tell brandon about it now it is time for
final judgment people what do you think
i think that this is amazing theory
myself so i'm gonna give you a big old
thumbs up rogus
actually okay bro guess row guess if i
had a third thumb
oh you do have a third thumb my friend
oh
[Laughter]
these were all amazing answers and just
amazing opinions in general um no winner
in this new format we're all winners
because i think you're both you both won
you both had world wars
one because your theories were done
give me money
give me give me money yeah it's
juneteenth [ __ ]
[Laughter]
amazing episode of rogue theory thanks
to our amazing guest jessica clemens
whitney van lenningham and off-screen
producer brandon you can support our
channel by checking out all of our dope
ass merch over at new rockstar's merch
and if you've got some rogue theories of
your own you can share them on our
discord if you are 18 years old or older
there's a link in the description
click it and you're there you can join
us you can follow me at mastertainment
on twitter you can follow the new
rockstars on all social platforms and
make sure to hit that notification bell
on youtube when you subscribe to us on
youtube because we
post things pretty much every day but
again thank you guys for being with us
today um it means so much to us and we
will see you guys next time we love you
bye
[Music]
you